new information and new testimony from
the january 6 committee to the committee
rather from former acting attorney
general jeffrey rosen and two other
conservative republican officials
appointed by then president trump
rosen's deputy said that then president
trump who had legitimately lost the
election then tried to get the justice
justice department to lie about it lie
about fraud that is so he could stay in
power again even though he had just lost
the election
you also noted that mr rosen said to mr
trump quote doj can't and won't snap its
fingers and change the outcome of the
election how did the president respond
to that sir
he responded very quickly and said
essentially
that's not what i'm asking you to do
what i'm just asking you to do is just
say it was corrupt and leave the rest to
me and the republican congressman
the former d.o.g doj rather leaders say
trump's pressure campaign hit a boiling
point when he almost replaced rosen with
assistant attorney general jeffrey clark
now that's noteworthy because clark had
no criminal law experience none but they
say he was willing to act on the false
claims of election fraud they testified
that on that day they assured trump
there would be mass resignations if he
went through with the plan
clark testified to the committee earlier
this year and asserted his fifth
amendment rights
125 times his home was searched by
federal agents before yesterday's
hearing clark calls this investigation
highly politicized cbs news chief
political analyst john dickerson joins
us at the table they said yesterday's
table good to see you john good to see
you again i'm always glad when john is
here they said yesterday's testimony was
could be considered some of the most
crucial so far what did you make of
yesterday's hearing well we've seen the
drama that happened in public the riot
on january 6. this was the drama we
didn't see that was happening behind
closed doors and that meeting in the
oval office where the top leadership of
the justice department threatened to
resign that was people standing up right
we've seen a lot during the trump years
one of his talents was teaching people
to lie down sometimes people who knew
they should stand up knew something was
going on that they should speak out
about they didn't say anything here you
had people stand up in the moment and
that matters because the ideas like free
elections the rule of law the will of
the people those only exist if people
stand up for that idea we've seen over
the last four years that when people
don't stand up those wither away and if
those wither away
you don't have it what i find so
remarkable about these hearings is that
these are not people talking to
reporters these are not people giving
speeches these are people under oath who
were conservative republicans who voted
for the president supported the
president work for the president so with
that in mind what do you make of the
hearings overall at this point so that's
a key point both uh and and what i make
is that this was not just about january
6. this was a 78-day effort the minute
donald trump knew he lost the election
he worked for 78 days every possible way
he could i mean it was like a burglar
who first tries the front door then the
window then the mail slot then the dog
door these were all individual gambits
and and what i mean is pressuring the
vice president pressuring the officials
in the states whipping up the crowd now
we learned about what he tried to do at
the justice department this was a
relentless and by the way he was
supposed to be presidenting at that time
but he spent two and a half months
working on this and it's just as you
point out we're learning this from the
voices of insiders from family members
from those and that gives it much more
weight and credibility given the current
climate our country's leaders as divided
as the citizens can these hearings
achieve
something
that could prevent this from happening
again i think it's a great question nate
yes because those those ideas i talked
about they are what keep us in balance
you know america has has run over those
bright lines about the will of the
people the rule of law and it gets back
in balance when people stand up there
are a lot of people who have stood up uh
in these this testimony we've heard
about them and it requires all of the
rest of us members of the president's
party democrats citizens to say this
standing up is the behavior we want we
are a country of of laws because the
founders said you know what's going to
happen you're going to get so passionate
you're going to decide you know the laws
don't matter because what i believe i
believe so strongly so let's just do
what we want and we'll figure out the
laws later you can't run a customer it
seems like those who stood up wanted to
be on the right side of history because
they know that at some point they were
going to be questioned about this moment
and whether that was because they were
thinking predictively or they genuinely
felt that this is wrong and i have to
stand for something well that's right i
mean a lot of people get into this whole
business of public life because they
believe in a certain set of ideas and
that that that gives them warmth in
their heart because they believe those
ideas lead to a better america and it
seems like there were a lot of people
who weren't nourished by those ideas but
a lot of the people who stood up were
nourished and stood strong under
incredible pressure and by the way
pressure that's still going on wow when
i was watching that hearings think about
the the violence that we've seen and
that we're still seeing when you testify
in public like this right you are
inviting uh make yourself a target that
kind of heat but there are still people
who are standing up saying that that
election was a fraud they're calling it
highly politicized a witch hunt blah
blah blah we've all heard it before what
do you make of the republicans who still
say
that this there is no there there
there's still many of them that still
believe well i don't know if they
actually believe it but they're still
saying it publicly well you had the the
ranking republican chuck grassley this
in the senate say that that meeting in
the white house that oval office meeting
was just the president getting advice
about a policy idea that's like saying
the burglar who doesn't break into the
house was just interested in residential
architecture
unless you call a thing by its name
those lines disappear right so if you
wave this away you wave in more like it
why because there are a lot of people
who think apocalyptically in politics
right now they think we are at a
dangerous moment and we got to do
anything we can rules don't matter these
hearings really matter though john don't
they matter because we have to reassert
the idea that even if you're passionate
about something you can't blow off the
rule of law you can't blow off the will
of the people these ideas matter because
if you blow them off you have chaos
and to nate's point they matter for
history as well yeah
future historians will be watching john
dickerson thank you very much